Hello, Dr. Kevin Conner's again with a brief little presentation on vitamin D deficiency and cognitive
Declined
Interested article that just was published recently in neurology
About vitamin D deficiency and can they use that as a measurement of how people are doing cognitively and
And a possible early dementia signs they took over 1900 elderly subjects and they measured
There are 25 hydroxy vitamin D levels. That's what we would measure on a person if you had a vitamin D test
And then they were given a midi mental state examination which is a standardized
Examination given for a cognitive function
Interested findings they said subjects with a vitamin D level of less than 50 or
They described in this subject was a vitamin D level less than 50 was actually a
Deficiency and they said anybody with an insufficient vitamin D level was 50 to 75 which is
Interested how they put that in this in this article because most doctors would test a person's vitamin D level
And if they were 33 they'd say they would be normal. That is just not normal. We want vitamin D levels
High as possible. I like to see patients vitamin D levels 80 to 120
So regardless of what your doctors say there is really
Zero chance of having high vitamin D levels and at a risk of kidney stones
It has just been proven over and over that that just is not true. Well they found that subjects with a vitamin D level of
Less than 50 or 50 to 75 even were more likely to have declining MMSE scores
That means they were more likely already showing early sides of dementia
And they said in the article quote was a strongly and independently associated these
Vitamin D levels of less than 75 was strongly independently associated with higher risk for onset of cognitive decline
So we need vitamin D though surprise there. How do we get it? Well
You get it from the sunlight right well getting vitamin D from the sunlight
Requires a couple things it requires direct skin exposure with the sunlight and
Our clinic is a bit of soda that's what we're from but even if you're if you're going down to
Arizona in the winter time if you're not getting skin exposure to vitamin two
Sunlight you are not effectively converting that sunlight
Into vitamin D. So what what happens is when you when the sunlight hits your skin you are taking a chemical in your skin called
7D hydro cholesterol and it's converting it into a pre vitamin D3 in your skin
So if you don't have direct skin exposure you're not going to get the vitamin D from the sunlight
It also requires in order for you to get vitamin D from the sunlight you have to have that precursor you have to have that
7D hydro
cholesterol in your skin
Here's a little a little
Off a little secret with the whole
Decrease cholesterol movement that's out there people that are taking
Lipitor and other statins to decrease cholesterol are decreasing the 7D hydroxy cholesterol in their skin
So one theory behind the increase in skin cancer
over the course of the last
several decades increase
Incidents of skin cancer over the last several decades is the use of the stat medications stat medications
Effectively decrease cholesterol, but they also decrease cholesterol
Derivatives cholesterol is made in your liver for a purpose cholesterol is the precursor to all your hormones
Vitamin D is actually a hormone in your body. So the cholesterol is the precursor for 7D hydroxy cholesterol
So if you effectively decrease cholesterol through using a stat medication you are decreasing the derivatives
That cholesterol forms and you are increasing your
Your likelihood of vitamin D deficiency in your body so just another reason not to take statin drugs
Among the many many reasons not to take statin drugs
And that many reasons not to buy into the whole cholesterol myth
So you need that precursor that 7D hydroxy cholesterol and your skin in order for you to make
Vitamin D3 in through sunlight
Now most of us they stood my deck in the woods do not get adequate sunlight in the winter time
It's just almost impossible if you're going to go and expose your skin to the sunlight
In the winter time in Minnesota you are going to also have frostbite
So how do you deal with the decrease vitamin D in the winter time? Well you can get it from your food
That's one thing but I tell almost everybody to supplement with vitamin D3
So you want to use vitamin D supplementation this is the ones I use
There's multiple of the liquids like this dropper bottle that are out on the market that are really really good
A matter of fact there's probably only a few manufacturers that actually make it in a different supplement companies
This is designed for health product vitamin D3
The nice thing about the liquid droppers is that typically one drop is about 2000 iUs of vitamin D
Some of them are a little bit watered out so one drop is 1000 iUs of vitamin D
But what we use is one drop is 2000 iUs of vitamin D
So if you take 5 drops you have 10,000 iUs in simple to take
You put it by your toothbrush and your drawer fits nicely in the drawer
So if you take 5 drops it's fairly tasteless even kids could use it that's the reason why I like this dropper bottle
So there's doses that I put on here 5000 in the summer and 10,000 in the winter
This is really based on someone who's not really even sick
So if a person is dealing with cancer sometimes we want to even up it greater than that
At least for a period of time remember I would like people's vitamin D levels
Really between 60 and 120, 80 and 120 out of vitamin D test
When a person is autoimmune it tends to your immune system tends to gobble up vitamin D in your body
The high need for vitamin D is even greater
So many people with autoimmune disease you measure their vitamin D levels
And it's really in the tank
A lot of people with cancer you measure their vitamin D levels and it's very low as well
So many times we'll start them at 20,000 a day for the first few weeks of the dropper down to 10,000 a day
In the summer the person is getting outside and they have a blood test that shows a fairly normal cholesterol level
Which means their cholesterol really should be between 180 and 250 is where I want my patients cholesterol levels
That's another discussion itself
This picture here also shows a vitamin D supreme which also has a vitamin K in it which could be good for
Vitamin K is also helpful for getting calcium into the bones
So if you're trying to take vitamin D for multiple reasons
A lot of times people will take vitamin D because they're trying to prevent osteoporosis which is another discussion in itself
But then vitamin K can be helpful
So the vitamin D capsule here has vitamin K in it and a few other things
But some people like to take capsules easier
So these ones that I like here and you can get them elsewhere are these capsules are 5,000 I use
So you just need to take two of those, it's simple to take
So vitamin D deficiency is huge in our country and it's necessary usually to supplement
It's so easy to supplement, it's very inexpensive to supplement vitamin D
So something I'd highly suggest
Alright Dr. Cutters, talk to you again